GREAT SHOW, TUCKER AND HANG IN
THERE.
WE ARE ALL BEHIND YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
DAY TWO OF THE SCANDAL THAT'S
ROCKING THE ENTIRE WORLD OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
DOZENS OF WEALTHY FAMILIES,
BUSINESS EXECUTIVES AND YES,
HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITIES CAUGHT
RIGGING THE SYSTEM, PAYING HUGE
CRIMES, FIXING S.A.T. AND ACT
SCORES, ALSO THEIR LITTLE
CHILDREN, THERE ARE SKIDS COULD
GAIN ADMISSION INTO SOME OF
AMERICA'S TOP UNIVERSITIES
THE MEN AT THE VERY CENTER OF
THIS FRAUD IS NAMED WILLIAM RICK
SINGER.
HE IS COOPERATING WITH FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES APPARENTLY NAMING
NAMES.
HOURS AGO, FULL HOUSE ACTORS
LORI LOUGHLIN APPEARED IN COURT
TO FACE CHARGES FOR HER
INVOLVEMENT IN THIS GAME AND
WAS RELEASED.
A ONE MILLION-DOLLAR BOND.
THE SAME AMOUNT AS OUR KELLY.
SHE HAD HER HUSBAND ARE ACCUSED
OF PAYING HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THEIR TWO DAUGHTERS COULD
GET INTO USC AS PURPORTED CREW
ATHLETES.
THEY NEVER WERE CREW ROWERS
EVER.
THEY NEVER PLAYED ONCE.
THEY EVEN WENT AS FAR AS TO
PHOTOSHOP PICTURES.
FELLOW ACTRESS FELICITY HUFFMAN
WAS ARRESTED AT GUNPOINT DURING
A RAID BY MULTIPLE FBI AGENTS
AFTER SHE WAS ACCUSED OF PAYING
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO FAKE HER
DAUGHTER'S S.A.T. SCORES.
ACCORDING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, STUDENTS
WHO BENEFITED FROM THIS FRAUD
MAY NOW GET KICKED OUT OF THE
COLLEGE.
THAT SHOULD BE THE LEAST OF
THEIR WORRIES BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS NOW APPARENTLY THEY WILL
BE FACING UP TO 20 YEARS BEHIND
BARS.
SO FAR, 50 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CHARGED INCLUDING MULTIPLE
COLLEGE ATHLETIC COACHES, SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, SEVERAL S.A.T.,
ACT OFFICIALS AND FRAUDSTER
WILLIAM RICK SINGER CLAIMED
TO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY SERVICED
OVER 80800 CLIENTS WHO PAID HIM
TENS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS ON IN
SOME CASES MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHY?
STATUS, BRAGGING RIGHTS, SO THEY
COULD TELL THEIR FRIENDS THAT
THEIR PRIVILEGE CHILDREN GOT
INTO THE VESICLES EVEN THOUGH IN
REALITY THEIR CHILDREN WEREN'T
GOOD ENOUGH ACADEMICALLY OR
WEREN'T GOOD ENOUGH ATHLETICALL
ATHLETICALLY.
THEY STOPPED ON THE FUTURES OF
OTHER PEOPLE, THIS IS A ZERO-SUM
GAME, THERE'S ONLY SOME LISA
WATSON'S SCHOOLS
CHILDREN NOT US FINANCIALLY WILL
OFFER KIDS KIDS WENT TO WORK FOR
EVERYTHING, KIDS WHO PUT IN THE
TIME ACADEMICALLY OR
ATHLETICALLY, THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF HOURS STUDYING AND
TRAINING AND ACTUALLY EARNING
THEIR GRADES WERE POSITIONED IN
THEIR SPORT.
KIDS WHO SPENT ALL THIS TIME ON
AND OFF THE FIELD TO BETTER
THEMSELVES AND ENRICH THE SCHOOL
WITH THEIR INCREDIBLE ATHLETIC
ABILITY.
KIDS WHO PLAYED SPORTS
COMPETITIVELY, MOST KIDS NOW
THEY FOCUS ON ONE SPORT SINCE
ABOUT THE TIME THEY ARE SEVEN.
I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE LIVED
THROUGH.
IF FOUND GUILTY, THOSE INVOLVED
IN THE SCANDAL ARE THE NEW FACES
OF YES, GREED, CORRUPTION AND
SELFISHNESS IN A RARE MOMENT OF
HONESTY EVEN FAKE NEWS CNN
DONALD LEMMON SUMMED IT UP LIKE
THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS AN AMERICA THAT CAN
BE DEEPLY UNFAIR WERE HARD WORK
DOESN'T NECESSARILY PAY OFF.
WHERE IF YOU HAVE MONEY, YOU CAN
BUY ANYTHING BECAUSE JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING IS FOR SALE.
INCLUDING INTEGRITY.
FOR SALE.
A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE REAL
GOOD REASON TO BELIEVE THE
SYSTEM IS RIGGED AGAINST THEM.
LISTEN, THIS IS WHAT
DONALD TRUMP TAPPED INTO AND IN
A LOT OF WAYS, GUESS WHAT, HE
WAS RIGHT.
>> Sean: THANKFULLY 2020
DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS WERE VERY,
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
LIFELONG FRAUDSTER HERSELF
ELIZABETH WARREN, SHE IS
WEIGHING IN ON THE CONTROVERSY
BECAUSE AT THIS TIME OR A TIME
LIKE THIS, WARREN IS EXACTLY THE
MORAL COMPASS AMERICA NEEDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AS A PARENT, HOW MUCH
SYMPATHY WOULD YOU HAVE FOR
THESE PARENTS WHO ARE EMBROILED
IN THIS ALLEGED CHEATING
SCANDAL?
>> ZERO.
>> Sean: THE SAME ELIZABETH
WARREN, SHE LAID ON HER TEXAS
BAR REGISTRATION, PROBABLY LIVE
TO MOST OF HER EMPLOYERS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION HARVARD TELLING
THEM SHE WAS NATIVE AMERICAN
LITERALLY FAKING WHAT HER
RACE AND BACKGROUND WAS TO GAIN
AN ADVANTAGE, SENATOR WARREN THE
POSTER CHILD FOR FRAUD IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY 2020
DEMOGRAPHICS AND CLAIMS OF
RAMPANT HYPOCRISY.
INTIMATES 2020 HANNITY WATCH ON
THE ELECTION, THEY HAVE BREAKING
NEWS TONIGHT.
REMEMBER WHEN THE LEFT TOLD
AMERICA THAT ALL CLAIMS OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, THEY ARE TO
BE BELIEVED.
NO DUE PROCESS, NO PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE NECESSARY.
APPARENTLY DEMOCRATS DON'T APPLY
THAT SAME STANDARD TO
THEMSELVES, AS WE HAVE LEARNED
TONIGHT.
A FORMER AIDE TO ME TO CHAMPION
SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND FROM
NEW YORK ACTUALLY RESIGNED
AFTER CLAIMS OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WERE ALLEGEDLY
SWEPT UNDER THE RUG.
MEANWHILE, BERNIE SANDERS 2016
CAMPAIGN IS STILL DEALING WITH
ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
APPARENTLY BELIEVE ALL WOMEN IS
NOT A MOTTO FOR THE SENATOR'S
CAMPAIGN.
IT'S NOT ONE THEY BADE
THEMSELVES AND DON'T FORGET
KAMALA HARRIS.
ONE OF HER TOP AIDES FORCED TO
RESIGN BECAUSE OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT BUT ONLY AFTER
DETAILS OF HIS $400,000 PAYOFF
BECAME PUBLIC.
BRAVE SENATORS.
THIS WILL BE AN ISSUE IN 2020.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS LATER
IN THE SHOW BUT WE TURN NOW TO A
SERIOUS SITUATION OVER AMERICAN
SKIES TONIGHT OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION EARLIER
TODAY THE PRESIDENT ORDERED ALL
BOEING 737 MAX 8, 9 PLANES
GROUNDED IN LIGHT OF NEW
INFORMATION FROM THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CRASH OF
ETHIOPIAN AIRLINES FLIGHT 302.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: WERE GOING
TO BE ISSUING AN EMERGENCY ORDER
OF PROHIBITION TO GROUND ALL
FLIGHTS OF THE 737 MAX 8 AND THE
737 MAX 9.
AIRLINES HAVE BEEN ALL NOTIFIED.
AIRLINES ARE AGREEING WITH THIS.
THE SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND ALL PEOPLE AS OUR
PARAMOUNT CONCERN.
BOEING IS AN INCREDIBLE COMPANY.
THEY ARE WORKING VERY, VERY HARD
RIGHT NOW.
AND HOPEFULLY THEY WILL VERY
QUICKLY COME UP WITH THE ANSWER,
BUT UNTIL THEY DO, THE PLANES
WERE GROUNDED.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS
MAKING THE RIGHT MOVE TONIGHT.
HIS NUMBER ONE PRIORITY HAS
ALWAYS BEEN PROTECTING HUMAN
LIFE.
HE IS PRO-LIFE.
LOOK WHAT HE TRY TO DO WITH THE
BORDER, PROTECT AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
4,000 HOMICIDES, 30,000 SEXUAL
ASSAULTS, IN TWO YEARS AND
100,000 VIOLENT ASSAULTS BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
AGAINST AMERICANS.
LET ME BE MORE CLEAR.
I WANT TO SAY THIS ABOUT BOEING.
BOEING'S GREAT AMERICAN COMPANY.
THEY HAVE CREATED SOME OF THE
BEST MOST RELIABLE PLANES USE
WORLDWIDE.
I WANT BOEING TO BEAT THE FRENCH
OWNED AIRBUS IN THE OPEN MARKET
AND I KNOW THEY WILL.
ALL AMERICANS SHOULD BE ROOTING
FOR BOEING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS SERIOUS SITUATION
RESOLVE IT AND GET BACK TO
PRODUCING SOME OF THE BEST
AIRCRAFT THIS WORLD HAS EVER
SEEN AND SOME OF OUR FELLOW
AMERICAN CITIZENS, THEY BUILT
THIS AIRCRAFT.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING YOU THOSE
DEVELOPMENT'S AS THEY CONTINUED
ON FOLD.
FIRST RETURN TO OUR HANNITY
WATCH ON THE DEEP STATE.
WE HAVE MORE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
FOR THE PAST FEW NIGHTS RIGHT
HERE ON THIS PROGRAM, WE HAVE
BEEN URGING YOU TO JUST HANG ON,
BE PATIENT, BECAUSE JUSTICES
AROUND THE CORNER FOR ALL
HIGH-LEVEL GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT FOR TWO YEARS,
THOSE INVOLVED IN BRINGING
CLINTON'S INVESTIGATION SO SHE
COULD REMAIN THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE, THOSE INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO ALTER AN IMPACT
ELECTION WITH RUSSIAN LIES THEY
KNEW WERE ALLIES BUT THEY
DISSEMINATED THEM ANYWAY.
ALL WHILE PERSECUTING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN FOR SOMETHING HE NEVER
DID OR HIS CAMPAIGN NEVER DID.
TONIGHT I WILL LET CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES GIVE YOUR PREVIEW OF
THE COMING ATTRACTIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WE WILL MAKE KEYING SEVERAL
CRIMINAL REFERRALS WE HOPE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL TAKE
THESE OUT.
>> ONE OF THOSE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS GOING TO BE MADE?
>> SOMETIME IN THE NEXT TWO,
THREE, FOUR WEEKS.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE WAS IN THE
MILLER REPORT.
>> Sean: MY SOURCES TELLING ME
TONIGHT THIS WILL ONLY BE THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE HAPPENING IN
COMING WEEKS WILL BE MAJOR.
COULD SHOULD BE MAJOR, THERE
WILL BE MORE AFTER THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST COMING FROM
SENATOR NUNEZ, SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM WHO WILL JOIN US IN A
MINUTE.
KINO HAS REOPENED THE SENATE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FISA
ABUSE SCANDAL AND REMEMBER WE
STILL HAVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT WE
ARE WAITING FOR AS IT RELATES TO
INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ,
SENATOR GRAHAM AS I SAID WE'LL
BE HERE IN A MOMENT.
AND ALSO THANKS TO THE COURAGE
OF CONGRESSMAN COLLINS OF
GEORGIA, THE FULL TRANSPORT OF
THE LISA PAGE TESTIMONY, WE NOW
LEARNED YESTERDAY ON LEARNING
MORE TODAY THAT IT WAS OBAMA'S
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ACTUALLY
DIRECTING THE FBI NOT TO CHARGE
HILLARY CLINTON WITH THE
STANDARD IN THE LAW WHICH WAS
GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
ACCORDING TO LISA PAGE, "WE HAD
MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
CHARGING GROSS NEGLIGENCE AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
ASSESSMENT WAS THAT IT WAS BOTH
CONSTITUTIONALLY VAGUE, REALLY?
SO THAT THEY DID NOT ACTUALLY
FEEL THEY COULD PERMISSIBLY
BRING THAT CHARGE AND THEY
NEEDED A NEW STANDARD.
CONGRESSMAN RADCLIFFE ASKED "YOU
ARE MAKING IT SOUND LIKE IT WAS
THE DEPARTMENT THAT TOLD YOU
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO CHARGE GROSS
NEGLIGENCE WHICH IS IN THE
STATUTE BECAUSE THE PROSECUTORS
WERE TELLING YOU WE ARE NOT
GOING TO."
PAGE RESPONDED, THAT IS CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT?
THAT MEANS THIS WAS ORDERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OF
BARACK OBAMA HEADED BY LORETTA
LYNCH.
YES, THE SAME ATTORNEY GENERAL
AT THE TIME THAT MET DAYS BEFORE
THIS DECISION SECRETLY ON THE
TARMAC IN PHOENIX WITH
BILL CLINTON SUPPOSEDLY
45 MINUTES TALKING ABOUT GRAND
CHILDREN.
THIS WAS IN THE FINAL DAYS OF
THAT INVESTIGATION.
THE SAME PERSON WHO ASKED JAMES
COMEY, DON'T CALL THIS AN
INVESTIGATION.
WE CALL IT A MATTER.
REALLY?
THAT WASN'T AN INVESTIGATION?
SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
THE SAME PERSON WHO REPORTS
DIRECTLY TO BARACK OBAMA.
TONIGHT WE NOW HAVE ADDED A VERY
IMPORTANT NEW COMPONENT TO THIS
ENTIRE DEEP STATE ISSUE.
WHAT DID BARACK HUSSEIN OBAMA
KNOW AND WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
THIS NOW TAKES IT STRAIGHT TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND THE
OVAL OFFICE, BARACK OBAMA.
THANKS TO PAIGE, WE ALSO KNOW
THE TOP FBI INVESTIGATOR, HER
BOYFRIEND STRZOK VIEWED THE
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION, THAT WAS THE
INSURANCE POLICY THAT WE KNEW
THEY TALKED ABOUT.
AND THEY JOINED THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION IN ORDER TO BUILD
A CASE TO IMPUGN AND POTENTIALLY
IMPEACH THE DULY ELECTED NEW
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ASSUMING THAT ALL THEIR WORK AND
THE RELEASE OF ALL THOSE LIES
AND ALL OF THAT PROPAGANDA AND
THE DOSSIER THEY DISSEMINATED TO
INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BEFORE THE VOTE IN 2016.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS THERE WAS
COLLUSION BUT IT WASN'T TRUMP
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
ACCORDING TO PAGE, THE FBI HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE AFTER
THEY STARTED AN INVESTIGATION
AFTER EXONERATING HILLARY THIS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN IN JULY OF
2016, TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION.
BY THE WAY, THEY WENT ALL THE
WAY THROUGH MAY OF THE NEXT
YEAR.
THEY FOUND NO EVIDENCE.
THIS IS BEFORE BOB MUELLER WAS
EVEN APPOINTED.
THEY FOUND NOTHING AND HERE WE
ARE 665 DAYS LATER INTO WHAT IS
MUELLER'S INTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION STILL ZERO SIGNS
OF COLLUSION.
RAND PAUL SAID TODAY THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING THERE
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER, CORRUPTION SCANDAL WE'VE
EVER SEEN.
THE CONCLUSION OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE, DEVIN NUNES
COMMITTEE, NO RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THE BIPARTISAN SENATE
INVESTIGATION, NO RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
AND FOR MONTHS, SOME PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO TELL ME MUELLER
IS OF GOOD AND HONORABLE AND
DECENT MAN.
HE SERVED HIS COUNTRY.
SEMPER FI.
HE'S A MARINE.
IMPECCABLE INTEGRITY.
I HAVE WANDERED FROM DAY ONE WHY
DID BOB MUELLER'S STAFF THIS
POLITICAL INVESTIGATION WITH
ONLY DEMOCRATIC DONORS.
WHY WOULD HE EVER HIRE
HILLARY CLINTON SUPPORTERS AND A
FORMER CLINTON LAWYER AND NO
REPUBLICANS.
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER IF MUELLER
HAS PAID ATTENTION TO ALL OF THE
ABUSE OF POWER AND CORRUPTION WE
HAVE EXPOSED RIGHT HERE ON THE
SHOW FOR TWO YEARS.
I WONDER IF HE HAS THIS FIDELITY
TO TRUTH AND THE LAW.
YOU KNOW, SOON WE WILL ALL KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT.
BUT IT'S NOT A GOOD SIGN THAT
MUELLER, YOU KNOW, POINTS A GUY
LIKE ANDREW WEISSMANN.
REMEMBER ENRON THE ACCOUNTING
CASE, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE LOST HER JOB.
THIS GUY LICENSE TO LIE IN
SIDNEY POWELL'S BOOK.
WITHHELD EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
THAT'S MUELLER'S PIT BULL ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
THEN HE PUT FOUR MERRILL
EXECUTIVES IN JAIL FOR A FULL
YEAR.
THAT WAS OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT.
WHY WOULD HE EVER BE HIRED BY
MUELLER?
TODAY PAUL MANAFORT CASE,
LIBERALS AREN'T GOING TO BE
HAPPY AND LESS PAUL MANAFORT
DAYS IN JAIL.
HE WAS SENTENCED TO MORE PRISON
TIME FOR THE SECOND CASE WOULD
HE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN.
NONE OF THEM, WE NOW HAVE TWO
CASES, NOTHING TO DO WITH
COLLUSION WHATSOEVER.
HERE'S HIS ATTORNEY EARLIER
TODAY.
LISTEN TO THE NICE LITTLE
PROTESTERS AND RESISTANCE IN THE
BACKGROUND.
>> JUDGE JACKSON CONCEDED THAT
THERE WAS ABSENTLY NO EVIDENCE
OF ANY RUSSIAN COLLUSION IN THIS
CASE.
THAT MAKES 2 QUARTS.
TWO COURTS HAVE RULED NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY COLLUSION WITH
ANY RUSSIAN.
PART NUMBER TWO.
--
[SHOUTING]
>> VERY SAD DAY FOR SUCH A --
A SENTENCE THAT'S TOTALLY
UNNECESSARY.
>> Sean: OF THE JUDGE IN THE
METAPHORIC CASES PUSHING BACK
SAYING THAT THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION IS NOT YET OVER.
OKAY.
TONIGHT WE HAVE TWO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE BEST
SIGN THAT MUELLER IS NOT GOING
TO FIND ANY RUSSIA COLLUSION
THEN LOOK NO FURTHER THAN THE
COWARDLY SHIFT HIMSELF, ADAM SCH
COWARDLY SHIFT HIMSELF, ADAM SCF
COWARDLY SHIFT HIMSELF, ADAM SC.
TODAY BUSY IN HIS FAVORITE
CONSPIRACY BASED NETWORK MSNBC.
SHIFTING THE NARRATIVE,
SQUIRMING WHEN ASKED A SIMPLE
QUESTION ABOUT HIS PREVIOUS
GRANDIOSE CLAIMS THAT HE HAD
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
TAKE A LOOK AT MY FRIEND WHO
USES MY NAME TO RAISE MONEY.
HERE'S THE COWARDLY SHIFT.
>> TWO YEARS AGO AS YOU POINT
OUT UNTIL THE PRESENT DAY, THERE
IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
BUT WHETHER THAT EVIDENCE
AMOUNTS TO PROOF BEYOND
REASONABLE DOUBT OF CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY WOULD HAVE TO WAIT
FOR BOB MUELLER TO DETERMINE.
IT IS STILL VERY MUCH MY VIEW
THE BEST EVIDENCE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S COMPLICITY AS A
GENERAL MATTER IS THE FACT THAT
HE HAS BEEN SO DECEPTIVE ABOUT
ALL THESE CONTACTS TIME AFTER
TIME.
>> Sean: NOW THE COWARDLY
SCHIFF IS TRYING TO SHIFT THE
CONVERSATION AWAY FROM
COLLUSION.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> IF THERE IS INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE IN THE MUELLER REPORT
AND WE ARE NOT ABLE TO PRODUCE
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE IN OUR OWN
INVESTIGATION THAT ENDS THE
INQUIRY.
THERE MAY BE GROUNDS FOR REMOVAL
FROM OFFICE OR THERE MAY BE
GROUNDS FOR INDICTMENT AFTER HE
LEAVES OFFICE THAT THE CONGRESS
DISCOVERS.
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE ARE LOOKING
AT WHICH THE MUELLER REPORT MAY
NOT COVER IS WHETHER THE
RUSSIANS WERE LAUNDRY MONEY TO
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
OUR PREDOMINANT CONCERN IN MY
COMEDIANS WAS THIS PRESIDENT, IS
THIS PRESENT COMPROMISED BY A
FOREIGN POWER?
>> Sean: OH, RIGHT, SO THERE'S
NO COLLUSION, THAN HIS COMMITTEE
IS NOW GOING TO SPEND -- WE'VE
BEEN THREE YEARS IN THIS.
THIS STARTED IN JULY OF 2016.
THEY WILL JUST KEEP
INVESTIGATING TRUMP UNTIL THE
END OF TIME.
WERE GOING TO BE INVESTIGATING
WHAT TRUMP DID IN NURSERY SCHOOL
BEFORE THIS IS SAID AND DONE.
HOPING TO FIND ANYTHING, THEIR
RAGE, THEIR HATRED IS BEYOND THE
PALE.